here tonight this is our annual Yahoo's
lecture which is our biggest event of
the year and I'm very pleased to welcome
and introduce here Professor Peter Zampa
from the University of Oxford who is a
noted historian of design - and not just
that and I think that's the interesting
part reading he Sibley actually made me
recall a lecture we had two years ago
but you have to miss Cooper who spoke
about Patrick Leigh Fermor
and the reason why I made his comparison
is that if you look at his very interest
at Peters various interests that range
from history to contemporary affairs to
running hotels in the Mediterranean to
sports of all kinds to music of very
sophisticated nature you realise that
he's a man of many talents in many
dimensions very much like a lot of real
an Oxford graduate that the Special
Operations Executive used during the
Second World War to create sabotage
actions again
no such thing in your CV sir folder yeah
so Peter got his BA at Cambridge and his
PhD at Oxford and he's been teaching at
Oxford since then he has been very
extensive year but highly specialized
scholarly I will single out his
translation for example of the alexia
which is one of the most interesting
historical contemporary story telecoms
very recent in Empire but he's also
written about the First Crusade and most
recently he's written is very
interesting very thick and very broadly
encompassing seek roles in new history
of the world which is going to inform
his talk today which says connects the
study of Byzantium with the challenges
of the contemporary world most not
abused in area of the world which is
very not very well studied and even less
understood especially in the United
States just to give you a sense of the
broad range of scholarship and how that
informs both his research and his
perspective I'll just mention that this
book draws on sources in Greek Latin
French Italian German Dutch Spanish
Portuguese Swedish Russian Arabic
Turkish Persian Hebrew Syria and Chinese
have I missed something in Doha there
must be something missing here so it's a
great pleasure welcome you here thank
you very much for honoring us with your
presence and we very much look forward
to your presentation tonight thank you
thank you very much indeed it's a real
pleasure to be here a real honor to
follow in the footsteps of so many very
distinguished scholars who come to speak
at Yale for this annual Stavros Niarchos
foundation lecture I am very humbled to
be here and thank you for giving up an
evening in the sunshine when you could
be out with a glass of white wine a cold
beer for choosing to come here instead
so I will try to make the evening as
lively as possible I think we have happy
to have questions off to it I think if
that's part of the the drill but thank
you very much for inviting me professor
Kelly bus also to John and to George for
arranging my visit like I said it's it's
a pleasure to be here I first came to to
New Haven about in the middle of the 90s
nearly 25 years ago and that made me
reflect on how the world has changed
since then
I'm a trial dad of the Cold War I left
school in 1989 and I travelled to the
United States in mind we have a year off
we used to have years off to try and
make us into men so we had arrived at
University ready to go and I visited in
1991 25 years ago exactly and I think
it's worth reflecting on how the world
looked at that time because since 1991
the world has been on the move but I
came here first at a time of great hope
in the world the Berlin Wall had just
come down there'd been a broadly a
revolution in Russia or attempted
revolution which led very quickly after
the shelling of the White House in
Moscow to the peaceful breakup of the
Soviet Union into 15 constituent
republics a transition that very few
people had expected I was a my first
love was really with Russian as a
teenage boy and the disintegration of
Russia happening without any major
violence this was a time when boundaries
were coming down across the world where
Mandela walked free and South Africa
transitioned again through Democratic
means
into a state which has its challenges
still today but again as a child growing
up
one never thought the transition would
happen that way in 1989 the date of the
Chinaman's Square protests despite this
very haunting and very famous image
China then set itself on a path towards
opening up and towards reform a process
that is not yet complete but China has I
think fair to say embraced many facets
of taking part within the family of
Nations that it hadn't done up until
that point February 1991 was a point
where the first Gulf War came to an end
where George HW Bush this time said very
clearly this is not a time for you forea
or a time to gloat this is a time to
focus on looking beyond victory and war
towards peace in the Middle East
and it seemed that the alignment of the
stars would make that happen with
agreements between Arafat and Rubin in
the early 90s as well and an
understanding at that time in the United
States government that regime change in
Iraq would be expensive as Dick Cheney
said when asked about it in the early
90s was it worth while removing Saddam
Hussein he said I have asked myself many
times how many US casualties that be
worth and the answer is not very damn
many that's a quote that optimism in the
early 90s gave way to an idea that we'd
reached something which was called
memorably the end of history a time when
the world had realized that political
political systems had realized that
liberal democracy were triumphs we'd
learnt in the 20th century at enormous
cost what persecution of minorities or
even majorities because of their
ethnicity their religion their skin
color their sexuality or their gender
led to we learnt emphatically that human
beings are capable of inflicting
profound suffering on each other and
that the virtues of those lessons
painfully learned was that that
transition to liberal democracy would
allow everybody to live in peace
and happiness in the future today 25
years later the world looks very
different we I think live at a time of
recognition of the fragilities and the
challenges facing us whether it's about
great populations whether it's about the
competition for resources climate change
new pathogens the Zika virus or the rise
of new ideologies the world today in
2016
feels a very long way removed from how
it did at that point of the death of
history at the end of history and these
themes have been picked up of course at
government level so the United States
Defense Department review in 2012 talks
very explicitly with an introduction by
President Obama of a transition of the
United States away finally from Europe
towards Asia a world being on the move
echoed in a British Defense Department
review that looks forward till 2040 this
is a time of great fragilities that we
all recognize and understand and these
challenges in front of us I think it's
striking to me all are in the same parts
of the world more or less here and I
think mapping individual crises on their
own sometimes means that we don't see
the big picture here if I have my
pointer I did have my point I never
turned my pointer away these are what
the current challenges in the world
which may escalate far beyond where we
currently see them I don't need to talk
to each of them cleanly problems in the
Middle East in in northern Iraq and in
Syria but also in Yemen in Libya to fail
the failure of the Arab Spring the Horn
of Africa Kashmir which I'm sure all of
you follow closely where there's been an
escalation in the last few months the
rise of the Taliban not just in
Afghanistan but putting pressure into
Tajikistan our neighboring countries and
took menaced on likewise pressure and
conquest of the alux ation of the Crimea
and eastern Ukraine potential flash
points in the South China Sea and
missile attempts
nuclear explosions I'm going upon in
North Korea just in the last week these
stars that I put on the map together all
have individually the potential to
impact our daily life in a very profound
way and each one of those potentially is
at a point where things can only get
worse rather than better I talked to a
friend of mine this morning and asked
who would be the Franz Ferdinand what is
the moment that changes the world today
to make this these fragile flash points
to make them even worse it's not
something which you can have a game game
look hang up afterwards but the impact
of this world in front of us all our
daily lives is profound it affects the
price of the gas we put in our car it
affects the price of the bread that we
buy in the shops when there was a ban
put on by President Putin about five
years ago on Russian wheat import
exports global wheat prices went up by
fifteen percent in 48 hours and that may
not be instantly noticeable here in new
haven so I think not noticeable back
home in Oxford but it is noticeable if
you live in below the poverty line in
these parts of the world that
interconnectedness and those complex
fragilities require I think a way in
which it might be worth looking at what
the world in the present day in a more
joined-up way than the specialisms of
looking at individual regions I think
one thing is clear though that we are a
long way from facing the end of history
because as far as the triumphs of
liberal democracy goes the world looks
very different to me these countries all
along the Silk Roads by the way which is
the hint of what I'm going to be talking
about these countries from the eastern
Mediterranean from Turkey through to
China all have several common
denominators they have a ruler at the
top who presides over what a historian
would call a royal court even if we're
not talking about royalty in its formal
meaning but presidential authority they
have lower human rights rankings there's
very limited press freedom restrictions
on freedom of worship
or downright prohibition low tolerance
of minorities zero tolerance in many
places on sexualities and opaque legal
systems in other words the antithesis of
that triumph of the liberal democracy
and I'm not going to talk today about
the the pressure on the concept of
liberal democracy in the Western world
but there are themes I think that are
tearing both the west as well as these
silk road countries in the same
direction of course the problem is we as
historians tend to focus very narrowly
on on Europe and the developed world to
the point that I saw a statistic last
month that says that in the UK 93
percent of history faculty specialize in
Western Western European history or the
history of the West including the United
States so when seven percent of the
faculty are focused on the world which
includes Latin America of course
includes Africa includes all of Asia
then it means that the students those
who are going to run businesses going to
be involved in the charitable sector
going to be involved in the political
decision making have a concept of the
past that will be far removed perhaps
from the reality and when I was a boy as
I said I was a child of the Cold War it
was striking to me that the only history
I learned about at school was that of
Europe and in fact it wasn't even the
history of Europe that I learnt about I
learned about history of this part of
Europe you're very fortunate here to
have a program in heroic studies but
broadly speaking all of you here I'm
logged into Oskar do a quiz but we can
all name a German philosopher or a
Spanish artist or a French novelist or
an Italian composer but when we start to
think about the contributions of
Hungarians to European culture of Poland
of Croatia Serbia Bulgaria Romania
Greece Ukraine very few of us are
engaged with the present or with the
past and that expands into other parts
of the world too how many people can
name a current Arab pop singer or a
great Indian film star
or the best Russian contemporary
novelist or a Chinese artist composer
philosopher a cultural figure from the
20th century that disengagement from the
past I think is a real problem
particularly at this moment of
transition and sorry I'll come back to
that in a second
in my own University Oxford which is a
very famous and distinguished
institution as just as a simple sign of
how disconnected we are from the reality
of the past there is in the Museum of
Natural History there are 27 busts of
the world's greatest scientists and all
of them are people you will have heard
of and expect to be there Charles Darwin
Galileo Ptolemy Euclid Pythagoras but
that's not a single figure recognized
amongst those 27 from the Arabic world
not one from India not one from China
let alone from from the continent of
Africa or the Americas and that
distortion of how we even understand
common concepts like the history of
science and the validity of scholarship
is something that I think needs to be
addressed in the modern world some
people call it you're a centrism and in
many universities the encouragement is
for students to use history like a
buffet and to go and learn to take a
course on Southeast Asian history or to
learn something about Mesoamerican
culture and society without ever trying
to see those connections and those big
joined up dots the world that I look at
and written about in my new book along
the Silk Roads which is a sort of
catch-all there is no Silk Road there
are no Silk Roads
it's a convenient capsule to explain
that intensive the intensive connections
that have meshed Asia together here I
show you some of the images from from
Samarkand here there's beautiful
stunning locations here Herat in western
Afghanistan that were once central to
global and intellectual life and to
global culture and politics and when we
think of the Silk Roads we tend to think
here in
from the inside the Shia mosque we tend
to think of camels long-distance trade
and of course the trade in silks and the
geography of the Silk Roads forbidding
difficult and treacherous but this world
was irrelevant I was never taught
anything about it and what I did know
what I learned about as I got older I
would have the name Genghis Khan and Tim
will throw at me and there's images that
I showed you evoke an exotic ism they
evoke a time when for some reason there
was a flourishing across the heart of
Asia and a sense that there was once a
disequilibrium to that past that I knew
something about from school but
fortunately I was my eyes were opened by
the discovery of the Byzantine world
when I was an undergraduate at Cambridge
it had never crossed my mind that the
history of half of our continent in
Europe had been written out of the story
and how that had happened and why was it
that parts of the world that well it's
being showered in rays of golden
brilliance had both been forgotten and
how had they been supplanted and as I
grew up looking around these the
buildings that I found most beautiful
I've been culturally tuned to admire
Chatsworth on the top left here images
from United States from your own city in
New Haven the courthouse this
expropriation of the classical world of
the architecture of ancient Greece
translate and transplanted all over the
world because we have rewritten history
to become heirs to the democracy of
Athens we've become heirs of the culture
of homer and a Virgil and the classical
world while ignoring the culture of
other related areas to the east because
it suited us to have that cassette
conception in the past and of course for
the Greeks that would come as a surprise
because the Hellenic world again I
talked about this earlier today with
George the Hellenic world was focused
entirely in its gaze to the east it
never crossed the mind of Alexander the
Great to conquer Europe when he wanted
to take over
world there was nothing of any value of
interest the Greek contribution to the
Mediterranean beyond the Peloponnese and
beyond the Aegean Sea were settler
colonies in Sicily and in the Adriatic
but Greeks knew that threat prestige
danger opportunity lay in Asia
hence the the obsession with the
Persians hence the great rivalry with
the Persians hence when Alexander wanted
to conquer the world he headed east this
is what mattered in the classical world
these connections that spreads statues
that brought ideas about culture about
art in both directions and when one
starts to read the Ramayana and sees
echoes from from the Iliad when one
starts to see borrowings from that
Virgil and Greek and Roman texts have
them from the Mahabharata and the great
Sanskrit works while start to look at a
world that is intimately interconnected
we live we live today convinced that
globalization is new but this world two
and a thousand years ago was one where
ideas where cultural forms where
political systems and fashion spread to
the point that those images today we see
of the Buddha that we're all familiar
with a well-fed figure who enjoys life
were brought in a influenced by statues
of the Greek god Apollo brought by
Alexander and his men into Central Asia
where the inroads of Greek theology
started to provoke reactions with
Buddhist mu Buddhism and what Buddhism
should mean and led to a reinvigoration
re understanding of what Buddhist ritual
should look like what Buddhist prayer
should sound like what it should how it
should entertain and those statues of
Apollo replacing very very rare statues
that predate to the 4th century BC those
very few that we have of the Buddha are
emaciated figures because of course as
all of you will be familiar but Buddhism
is about control
it's about self-denial it's about not
over indulging and the sudden influence
of the need to show and to link
prosperity with being well-fed
shaped ghandahar an art that then went
on to shape
even Buddhist images that we see today
and that process works in both ways so
that the halo the classic symbol in
Christian art is brought from from Asia
where Zoroastrianism and Buddhism the
sanctity of an individual immediately
recognised by the ring around the head
and this world was not just important to
the ancient Greeks who looked East Rome
looked East Rome was anchored in the
East because of the European Union
because of the way we tried to configure
the past because of the way we design
our buildings because of the way we
describe our aristocrats who in the 19th
and 18th century would be portrayed and
Britain wearing togas to look like Roman
senators but Rome's center of gravity
lay in the Nile in the first instance
Rome went from being a town on the shin
of Italy into being an empire with the
conquest of Egypt and the Nile and the
granaries but Rome's focus again as had
been the case with ancient Athens and
with Alexander was on the east to the
point that that the rival were in the
Parthian Empire drove conquest drove
trade drove ideas to the point that by
the 4th century Constantine the Emperor
Constantine decided to build a new Rome
closer to the action it was called new
Rome and in fact very soon as being
nicknamed the city of Constantine course
a Tonopah which looked that was designed
to look like Rome itself and when the
western roman part of the empire fell it
fell because it was essentially
expendable the heart kept on beating in
Constantinople for another thousand
years rebranded by later historians to
be called the Byzantine Emperor and
their byzantine empire but this was a
world that was entirely roman in fashion
and in fact roman in language until a
transition towards using greek in the
6th and 7th centuries that city of
Constantinople was the one which lit lit
me up I think a Miami
academic today because I discovered a
world that was unexploited unexplored
forgotten and yet the central point of
contact between these great continents I
did have my pointer what I was
what I was most excited about was seeing
how the Byzantine world connected with
the rest of these three great continents
which were separate from the Americas
until the voyages of Columbus and the
world that I worked on for my doctoral
studies was one that was multilateral
multi connected that joined culture from
Scandinavia and from Iceland visitors
from Iceland with one of my favorite
volleyball Essam who came to serve in
Constantinople in the 10th century in
the Imperial Guard and then came home
after 15 years or so a way to be met by
a crowd who formed over his luxurious
clothes that he was wearing these new
fashions that he brought back with him
from Constantinople and then till until
he realized that was one person not
waiting for him on the key his wife who
were standing waiting to give him a
talking-to the world where artisans from
Constantinople were sent to build the
Grand Mosque in Cordoba a world where
connections between concept and opal
created the states that became Russia
and Ukraine through trading nations and
trading systems linking the Black Sea
and the Caspian Sea with Scandinavia
where the in the the interventions and
cooperation and rivalry with the Arabic
of the Islamic caliphate in the 7th
century onwards provide valves for
communication across the Caucasus right
the way across Asia one of the most
exciting things that's happening today
is the sheer number of Byzantine coins
being discovered in graves in much as
Western China but in Pacific China to
this interconnected world where those
boundaries as intellectual boundaries
that we put up that configure Europe to
exist on its own isolated from the rest
of the world
is what I'm so excited about looking at
and I think it's time in this changing
world to look at these transitions
here's a map to show trading routes
2,000 years ago it's a little bit
simplistic but reports from southern
India the excitement of Indian traders
seeing the annual arrival of Roman ships
and Greek ships spraying foam over the
brows as they sailed to come and buy
pepper to come up by ceramics to come up
by textiles because
Europe didn't have anything of any value
and actually probably the truth is it
never has anything of any value Europe's
great systematized competitive advantage
was the preponderance Wars violence
Europe is a culture which has produced
castle building and castle building
techniques has produced all of the major
technological advances in weapons
development to the point that at the end
of the Second World War we developed
weapons in the West that were capable of
killing the entire world population the
process of how families could generate
and build up assets and protect them for
centuries with something that has a very
different profile across Asia where the
constant recycling of assets looks very
different and some of these big
questions are ones that I think more
historians could be looking at I saw her
interview with the late great David
Bowie doesn't get cited by too many of
my colleagues earlier this week saying
that the good work is produced when you
walk out into the sea just to the point
where your feet can't touch the bottom
and those of us who are historians who
know exactly how and when we are
comfortable and when when we're taking
some chances to go work or new different
and more complicated topics but it
seemed to me self-evident that this
world that I look at is the one that all
history and all this ruins should start
from because this part of the world
these connectors the web that links Asia
with it with one end of Asia cross the
other and to the Mediterranean is where
everything happened this is where our
ancestors first learnt to cultivate
wheat this is where our ancestors first
learnt how to build cities civilization
began in Mesopotamia right here in the
middle of the map these melt melting
point of where all the world's major
language groups collide the Semitic
languages the indo-european the Altaic
languages of the steppes the
sino-tibetan languages must be another
one something has a Caucasian very
complicated languages to the point that
when I come here to the United States
I'm not planning on being arrested this
evening but I'm I will if I do get
caught and busted I will be defined as a
Caucasian male
there is some connection we have still
with this part of the world but this is
where all of our major global religions
have either sprung from or competed with
each other this is where this cauldron
this heart of the world is where things
happen and this is the place I think one
can stand to look at and ask questions
about the past in antiquity the Middle
Ages as we call them at the early modern
the modern world and in fact the world
of tomorrow because those clusters those
clusters of stars of challenges and the
opportunities that also lie in this
region requires us to spend some time
studying those countries peoples
languages and so on and it's not just
trade that flows through these systems
it's not just ideas so to do pathogens
so I map here on this map in the thick
black line the spread of the Black Death
which rises from Central Asian plague
foci probably triggered by a climate
event that leads to a sudden rising
global temperatures by probably one to
one and a half degrees centigrade that
changes the antek cycle of the parasite
that spreads through fleas particularly
and kills eventually 25% or so the
population of Europe in the Middle East
these connections we have between us are
across Asia are the ones that matter and
many of them are very localized we're
not it's it's wrong to think of the Silk
Roads running and linking China with the
West most of the traffic most of the
trade along these connectors are
localized and we know that because how
we engage with our neighbors we know we
see our neighbors more often than anyone
else and we get annoyed with our
neighbors more often than anyone else
and exotic visitors from Oxford normally
you can arrive and leave without
provoking confrontation and so on
because the the exotic ism of a new
arrival is particularly interesting but
actually the day to day is important and
that low hum of constant burrowing along
the spine of Asia means that the rhythms
of cooperation the rhythms of violence
look very different because until about
1600 or so prosperity and tolerance were
to be found in the east these beers are
all linked it's no surprise I think
today
where we see the rise at the far-right
in Europe the disappointment with
political elites through brexit perhaps
through the current election that you're
going to have in November here when they
call it when the equipment when when
when the when the economics start to
stagnate people start to ask different
questions when it when inequality starts
to rise people start to look for
different answers and the rhythm unlike
Europe where there's a lot a decade
between 1350 and the end of the Second
World War that where there's not some
European violence where there's not a
war involving European powers should I
say the profile of exchange in Asian
looks different because this was the
richest part of the world trade is a
very positive thing to make to make
exchange and to allow people to give
each other the ability to express
themselves because when you're
self-confident you are able to show the
best parts of our characters as human
beings compassion kindness creativity
sponsorship of scholars 500 years ago if
I'd been my equivalent wouldn't have
been anywhere near New England I'd have
been in baccarat or in Isfahan or maybe
Mosul or Samarkand and you would have
been 2 scholarship translated and moved
towards Europe as a result of the fact
that Europe took control of these
trading net mechanisms first through the
discovery of the Americas I've got a
picture of Columbus but also through the
discovery of a route around southern
Africa to India and that European
technological those advances that
pressure to innovate which has lots of
different explanations for it allowing
bigger ships to be able to transport
transport more over longer distances
quicker enabled Europe to connect into
these global trading mechanisms and the
winner in that process was Western
Europe and the loser was Eastern Europe
and eventually the loser became Asia
itself as trading partnerships soon
became empires but what happened through
the process of this sudden integration
of all the world
into global trading systems was that
boolean flowed from the Americas
particularly from central and southern
America in the first instance into Spain
and into actually the Dutch Republic and
into Britain and that flow of cash
didn't just enrich those local
populations at the expense of course of
the Native American populations but they
were used to suddenly invigorate those
who are selling in the East in India and
in China particularly to the point that
leaders in India were suddenly able to
afford to commemorate their dead spouses
in this kind of fashion and Columbus who
had been trying to not find if I died if
the world was round or to see if there
was anything there Columbus was trying
to find trade routes through to India
and to China and was convinced as many
were that he found some some parts of
India unexplored but there's some irony
I think that the wealth of the Indians
as they were called funded the jewels of
the real Indians here on this part of
the world these interconnections very
important and very revealing that
process of building Empire meant that
the pressure to find new ways to secure
those assets became increasingly
intensive here in the sort of the 20th
century the transition was no longer
toward silks ceramics textiles spices
that characterized trade in the early
modern world but to new black gold oil
and that process of retaining control
over oil wells has shaped the world that
we see today
of course here with the sykes-picot map
on the top top right after the discovery
of oil in vast quantities in Persia and
in Mesopotamia and it's not just the
site speaker the Treaty of Sevres that
follows but that competition which even
in the First World War was being
described by the British a Cabinet
Office as a major a priority of British
war aims by the Second World War the
United States was calling it the United
States diplomat was calling the oil of
the Middle East
the greatest single prize in human
history and the attempt of the West to
tried to keep hold of access to that oil
has of course had the obvious long-term
implications it's had the implication
eventually of regime overthrow by the
Ayatollah Khomeini in 1979 I'm not even
going to talk about the Iraq war or bin
Laden but the attempts of the West to
try to intervene for good and for bad in
these parts the world to keep control of
those trade networks and to retain
political and economic influence driven
by the pressure of of oil the world
looks very different at the moment from
China's point of view because although
we are obsessed about the fragilities of
the world our political systems and the
quality of life China even in the state
of its new normal is taking a slightly
more optimistic and more pragmatic view
to how to see the world
here's Xi Jinping in Astana in
Kazakhstan three years ago talking about
his new signature economic and foreign
policy called the one belt one Road
initiative that essentially is a series
of massive infrastructure investment
into pipelines into high-speed rail
links into energy development into local
poverty alleviation zin and towards
energy projects for example in Pakistan
that this is much about securing China's
own long-term economic needs as it sees
them but also to understanding that that
world of Asia is going to solve its own
problems and that the West's chances of
trying to do so have run their natural
course and this new one road one belt
initiative I think is about a new world
that's forming in front of our eyes to
me as a historian I have no ability to
look forward into the future but I am
able to see that the pivot that Obama
talked of that rise of something in the
in the East in Asia is something that is
taking shape in front of our eyes at one
extreme through its religious
fundamentalism of Isis
but other extremes attempts of states to
try to find solutions for themselves
tried to find new ways of cooperating
through the Shanghai Cooperation
Organization through currency swaps
through oil swaps to try to manage
relationships which the west are
conspicuous by their absence and these
new connectors I think are profoundly
important and will have a huge impact on
the world
in front of us last month China
announced that it was going to quintuple
gas imports China's energy needs are
expected to travel in the next thirteen
or fourteen years and access to raw
materials even at a time of economic
stagnation is important to plan for the
future the short termism of our
democratic system turns out to be our
Achilles heel politicians who need to be
elected every four years a presidential
campaign that runs through two year
cycles before new candidates get chosen
don't allow for long term planning it's
a reaction to events that's how we've
learnt the frailties of democracy but
this also this world presents
opportunities and to that extent it's
the sort of it's the perfect invitation
to be here today in Yale at the Stavros
Niarchos foundation because there's a
train lines shown on to because Stavros
Niarchos and the foundation that he
endowed were built at exactly this time
of transition the shipping fleet that
grew in the 1950s and 1960s understood
that there was the need for
technological change the New Yorkers
fleet was famous for innovating and
creating bigger bigger tankers bigger
ships and trying to understand that the
world's needs of matching buyer and
seller would be closer together and that
those who could exploit and understand
those rhythms of who needs what and
where that that would be where fortunes
could be made and that's where the smart
money should be looking and the Archos
to that extent was very similar to other
oils in the engine like the sogdians who
produced the culture here on the walls
in Padua Kent in Central Asia and there
is some I think rather charming and
that you can compare the Saltine camels
that transported goods from one side of
the world to the other with the New York
cost shipping fleets that did exactly
the same thing those who are able to
understand the world are able to engage
from it and also to profit from it and
those who profit from it I think have an
obligation to give back and that's why
it's such honor to be here with the
patronage of the staffers New York OHS
foundation a very fitting but it's
particularly fitting to be here in Yale
because those students of you err who
will know everything about Elihu Yale
well know that Yale also was a man whose
fortune was made at a time of transition
who understood the world around him this
is written on his tombstone in in Wales
slightly on promising Lee in southern
Wales born an American in Europe bred in
Africa traveled in an Asia went where
long he lived and thrived in London dead
much good some ill he did so hopefuls
even and that his soul through Mercy's
gone to well even and Yale like Stavros
Niarchos endowed what was then called
the Collegiate School of Connecticut
that was so excited by this endowment
and was so pleased that there might be
more to come that they renamed the
University Yale in his honor and the
Archos and Yale and the sogdians
and the Armenians other communities that
have understood that the world is
changing and have reacted to it have
learned that they can do well from it
one of my favorite quotes and I start my
book with a quote near the top of my
book by a king of Zhao in China if 307
BC who says that to understand that to
understand the past and the present it's
not sufficient to follow the ways of
yesterday if you want to understand how
today is going to look you need to adapt
and that adaptation starts with
education and it starts with history
where we learn what's important where we
have curricula that teach the next
generation about regions peoples themes
topics that are important so I hope you
have a chance to read my book but it's a
pleasure to come here and talk to you
about parts of the world which has
professor
Oliva said don't often get airtime but
if you ask me is where we should start
looking at history rather than end it
thank you very much if they're gentle I
can handle questions yes asking who shot
jr. I don't want to reveal too many of
the surprises and jewels well I tell you
so one of the things that I've worked on
for a while is the rise of Europe in
from what used to be called the Dark
Ages so when I was at school most
people's concepts of history we learn
about the Romans and then the next thing
I was taught about was the Battle of
Hastings
that's my children learning too by the
way they're learning a history syllabus
that was would have worked 100 years ago
that thousand years is just passed by as
being irrelevant and what I wanted to
understand was how was it that Western
Europe starts to rise again that period
from thousand to zero to a thousand is
it's spectacularly interesting and
exciting if you look at Constantinople
the eastern Mediterranean the Byzantine
Empire and you see a world reacting
glorious glowing I don't have any slides
here of the churches that I could show
you but in the West people stopped
building in stone we can look at there's
a fantastic time to be a historian
because the resources we can use include
looking at ice cores from Greenland
where we can see what kind of levels of
pollution there were and after the fall
of Rome copper production in Europe
essentially goes back to prehistoric
doesn't say it goes back to prehistoric
levels people stopped being able to read
Charlemagne very famously well if you
were medieval historian Charlemagne used
to sleep with a writing board under his
pillow so he could practice writing
letters right writing you know spelling
his name
and his biographer Einhard says the
problem is he left it a little bit too
late in life sir never mastered the art
of writing European leaders couldn't
read couldn't write they built castles
and that I want to understand about that
dark ages what is it the galvanizes
Europe towards the more familiar picture
of castle building the Crusades the
knight in shining armor the papacy and
so on and as I sort of closet economic
historian I I don't always trust sort of
narrative sources but what we've got
lots of in early modern early medieval
Europe is data from coins and I was
amazed that when we start to see the
levels of coin finds linking Europe with
the Middle East particularly you start
to build up a profile of a scale of
human trafficking that is probably
greater than transatlantic human
trafficking and slave trades where the
amount of coins likely to be found
across the russian russian river systems
the Vikings were the great exponents of
the slave trade we think of the Vikings
as chaotic disorganized raping pillaging
and car and don't don't understand that
the smart Vikings went east the traffic
they did of human beings is to be
measured in silver coins probably
sampled into tens if not hundreds of
millions of silver pieces and that
boolean that starts to light up
Scandinavia is the driver that starts to
provide an economic boost to Europe and
when you start to read Turkic slave
buying guides Arabic say buying guides
that tell you about how to how to buy a
good slave in Baghdad or in Samarkand in
the eighty nine hundreds and you they so
don't ever pick a nice-looking guy with
floppy hair because you know he'll be
trouble make sure you always lie slaves
down and press them in the kidneys to
make sure that they don't have any
diseases wrong with them you start to
see that we have written that story of
Europe differently you know we don't
talk about slave trade in Europe we
don't think when we walk into a bar in
Rome or Venice to order a cocktail when
you say ciao you were saying Scoville
I'm your slave as a joke because Venice
was a huge trade slaving center to the
point that the Pope even had to tell off
Venice
Pease idli to stop selling slaves and
eventually the vinícius said ok but we
will we are allowed to sell people who
are not Christian right and the Pope
says yes and that name today we don't
think of but the Slavs gives us the word
slave such as the imprint of the impact
of human trafficking in the early Middle
Ages so it galvanizes European economy
it starts to produce the wealth allows
courtly culture to be built up it allows
connections with the East that by the
time of the Crusades mean that these
guys are not going into the black into
the abyss in guesswork of what's
happening in Jerusalem there's quite
good understanding a knowledge of what
Byzantium and what the arabic-speaking
world looks like and I think that those
those kinds of things at which there are
lots many different examples reinforces
the point that we have we are always
we've always been connected to each
other the only thing that's interesting
about the world today is the speed which
we do things and that has its own
challenges questions problems and so on
but that desire to travel that that need
for power that need for status that
needs to their willingness to subjugate
our fellow human beings I think is
something that in some ways I mean
funnily enough a couple of people have
said that they're they find they found
it quite reassuring to know that the
world has always been in transition and
that these changes of rhythm are nothing
to be worried about you can't manage
them but I think there were the slave
trade for example in the 9th and 10th
centuries the scale of it proved shown
by data is astonishing yes well you know
sort of hinted that I think with the
steps in the Archos Foundation and Yale
to have scholars have scholars you need
patronage you need to have people who
are rich enough to endow chairs to endow
scholars to build auditoria and the more
people who are able to give the better
the quality
of the research the better quality to
teach into better everything that's how
that's how that rhythm works and in in
Asia because Europe moves from being the
Europeans moved from being trading
partners to to imperialists particularly
the case of the British in India for
example then those assets start to shift
and you kill scholarship locally because
the money disappears so we have a long
tradition here of the last four hundred
years but I think it's no coincidence
there was no major seat of learning in
Europe beyond Paris and Bologna which in
the grand scheme of things are modern
compared to the seats of learning in
China Asia Constantinople and so on but
money and education tolerance prosperity
all lock in closely together the last
200 years
I suppose welcomed it the case that
communism in the first instance
nationalisms locally the attempts in the
first sensitive prioritize disengagement
from Empire in India in the Middle East
in Iran and so on have colored and
kneecapped scholarship but my assumption
would be as these parts of the world
start to rise again that the new
campuses in the new scholars will start
to congregate in these parts of the
world I think there is already a Yale
campus isn't there in them in the
Persian in the Gulf Haileybury a
secondary school from United Kingdom has
two campuses in in Kazakhstan you know
the ambition of a lot of these states
which have resources is to try and
attract the best of the best and in that
sense it's not just scholarship they
they patronize they've also bought the
best soccer teams so Parasurama AC Milan
Inter Milan Chelsea they're all owned by
Russians Chinese Persian Gulf there's an
Iranian there who owns Everton in the
Champions League in the Premier League
and in the UK to that process of using
your resources is is an important part I
think of understanding the rhythms of
history weird a particular bite point
right now because of oil probably cut
global commodity prices I'm not a
speculator I've got no no way to prove
what's going to happen next I think that
you know right now this is not a great
time for many of these oil producing
countries
because of new technologies because of
assumptions about where proven resources
might be but as a historian I can tell
you there's fragilities between Saudi
and Yemen Saudi and Iran any any lack of
resolution of Syria and Iraq increased
problems in in Ukraine
these fragilities are liable to produce
spikes that will then start to to change
the attitude so it's it's it's at the
moment most of these countries are
hitting super fragile status so Russia
has got its lowest reserves for since
since independence and is likely I think
the central bank in Russia says Russian
reserves will run out next year and
historians will tell you precisely tell
you that when that happens leaders and
states tend to make what looked like
irrational and very aggressive decisions
so that's the worst case scenario so
it's probably all our interests that
prices of oil and so on come up but that
rise of the East will start to attract
scholars I think yes
well it's not I don't want to over
promise so it's not something I can
speak over with any particular authority
but I'm but it is you know I'm a humble
historian I spend my days like many of
you do in a library it's not glamorous
it's not exciting it's it's hard work
and then you produce something that you
ask any Tom Dick and Harry to judge on
Amazon or in a review you know so it's
not it's not something one would
naturally choose to do but what is
incredible is that I think I'm most
surprised about my book and its
reception I'm very you know it's a
thrilled how it's been received all over
the world but in places like India
Pakistan and Central Asia and in China
the level of engagement about somebody
joining these dots together I mean I
went to Lahore why are people at Lahore
Airport wanting selfies with me that
doesn't happen I haven't 25 years I mean
to you 20 years I've been teaching in
Oxford not one of my students has ever
asked me for a selfie because there is
an idea that you are that there is a way
of connecting all these countries and
explaining their history and so I'm not
you know in terms of how they see their
own histories and what they teach I
think that there is an awareness and all
around the world that we're in a time of
change but giving voices to parts the
world that have a proud history that is
lost over has been very very important
you know I think that's the best thing I
could offer my contribution micro micro
contribution to humanities advancement
is to try to allow people to see that
the West hasn't always been on the top
that this wasn't a straight line from
Athenian democracy to Imperial Rome to
the Enlightenment and the renaissance
enlightenment and democracy because we
have a sense I think that we are the
in the West that people should be more
like us and one of the realizations in
with school as I talked to in the Arab
world and Russia Central Asia India and
so on is that that's true that we've
learnt these lessons but it's no
coincidence that the Holocaust is
perpetrated in Europe that genocide and
suffering is not something that it looks
familiar however awful the TV images are
on the news in the last ten years that
there is a there is a there is a way in
which this birth of something in Asia
may be something that has some positive
outcome so you know I think it's
important to try to put a context into
what history means and to try to try to
round things out so I don't know how
things are taught and perceived but I
think that this is a point of shifting
sands where people are deeply excited
deeply interested in trying to look at
world history in a different way yes
transnational enjoyed that and thank you
for that there's been a number of books
that have attempted as a extraordinary
history of the Mediterranean from
prehistory to make classical time that
attempts that it's almost that similar
sort of sweep with a quite different
sort of set of data and and subjects as
yours and so we've got this on the one
hand and then on the other hand we've
got the Academy and the publishers
pushing for hand books encyclopedias you
know that the guides of this this room
as a condensation of knowledge into
brain through atomistic short things and
they're books like yours the history of
the Mediterranean uncovering who wrote
it they after Rome inheritance of Rome
book again this transfer we sweep
history and I think where it's
interesting is what what what people
like to write now and what those who
storage right now is what will be taught
in the universities in the next five
years in the school to the next 10-15
years and it seems we've got two
different directions going on just
ponder with your crystal ball as a
historian I mean what's your hope for it
but in waiting
well I assure you do things differently
at Yale but in Oxford it takes six or
seven years to bring a new paper on on
board and like I said we know we we are
no no worse an ox in fact probably
slightly better in our sort of spare in
our in our engagement with non European
or Western in history you know I think
what's what's what's hard is that it's a
you know whether one likes it or not
history becomes a little bit like
fashion and and I'm sure that there will
be now lots of books writing sweeping
global histories and I'm sure lots them
will be terrific as well and we'll teach
all of us including me lots of things
I'd ever thought of and and then
there'll be there'll be something else
that's new and a new way of trying to
look at things what's difficult I think
is how do you how does one how does on
teach it one forgets about the themes in
history and how historians are writing
what are you trying to teach in history
classes to schoolchildren and university
students because it's very hard to cover
everything and when we specialize and we
all of us as academic historians when
I'm writing about 11th century poetry
and Byzantine world that I know that
there are five people in the world to a
much cleverer than I am but they're the
only people who will want to read it
there is a point at which we all have to
balance that engagement with the public
and with wider historians including
specialists actually and the kind of the
the fine detail work and I hope if my
book is good and it you know it's
perceived well by fellow historians it's
that it looks as it looks it stands up
when you stand like a picture when you
stand close up to it the define pointing
has to be right and I think that's the
thing I'm most proud of having written
it I don't know whether many people will
be able to do that many languages that
close up because it's it's you know I
was very very lucky with the way I got
set up
speaking Swedish as a boy learnt Russian
at school that's um Arabic at school you
know ended up having to bring my Greek
up to a stand of the the is you know to
be able to teach all the European
languages fell into place and then
pushing eastwards you know it's it's
hard to get that right and the problem
is I suppose that because we teach Latin
in Greek at schools it's very hard to
see how you take that across into
Eastern languages
setup and structure differently so I
don't know what's going to happen that
publishers do Commission and drive
things based on customers I think
probably students and customers today as
well and choose courses and choose
professors and choose the institutions
they want to work with but you can't
have one without the other you can't do
big history without the fine pointing
and so there is a tough tough balance I
personally I was talking about it just
now with Professor calamus actually I'm
quite happy I much rather write the
little stuff because I can have as many
footnotes as I like and you're not
watering things down so I mean there was
so much you know tons of stuff I did
weeks months on urbanization of cities
in the in the Dutch Republic and I
became one sentence you know but it but
you know if I convert very good on
urbanism in 1740s
and you know but you can't you can't
write it unless you go into that level
of detail so I think it's just getting
that balance right I'd no idea what the
book train will do but but you know the
good news is that people do by history
books and they buy quite thick history
books although I did say it's it's only
about 40 pages longer than 50 shades of
grey but people's reaction is my god
it's enormous but you know it's not it's
not that long but if but I mean that
gives us that I think that gives hope to
all of us I mean that's it's amazing
thing to write history book and people
to buy all over the world there is a
there is a real appetite so I was so
cynical academi thinking people don't
read anymore and they just play on their
Playstations and they're too busy having
cups of coffee with each other but
actually it can you can make it work
yeah and so you seem sort of critical
but I think you called the buffet model
where one might just take a token course
in some about some non German
philosopher non French novelist and so
I'm curious what do you think you know
one ought to do to really escape this
year a centrosome or broaden one's
horizons other than reading your book
it's sort of very meaningful
Wow well you know I think all right I
mean mister I'm all you can do is
historian is right about something you
think is interesting and provide your
own perspective that's it you know and
everybody will light light light taking
it like taking a photograph you know
that's my shot of what I think is the
best way of looking at what I can see in
front of me and I love to see what other
people's perspectives are and I think
that the point is not to harangue and
harass and say look this is a different
there's a different way of doing things
and all just read my book I think it's
that what I found most rewarding is
joining lots of dots together and one of
the problems we have as teachers and
well they probably have a students is
that the specialization you need you're
expected to drill down really tight and
that means it's very hard to come out
and know a bit about everything because
I'm you know you haven't got all your
life to specialize in something but I do
think that there is a way in which
trying to find out about lots of things
I mean it's truth my book isn't I mean
it is it is a history of the world but
it's not really because I don't write
about Chile or New Zealand or the
Pacific or not much about sub-saharan
Africa and you know but it's trying to
explain why we are where we are here
today and I thought that's the question
that a student would want to understand
why does the 2016 what what are the
problems in the world and why are they
as they are and you know if that means
that that's not to say that learning
about imperial ceremony in
Constantinople in the 11th century which
I teach has its value to but but again
it's the same answer which is trying to
juggle the two there's nothing wrong
with the buffet but it doesn't it
doesn't achieve anything yes
least in the knowledge certificate okay
over 5,000 years well we are you know I
think we I'm a little bit jet-lagged so
I'm not at my most fluent I promise I
apologize you know I think we we have a
capacity of light and lightness and
darkness as a as an animal human beings
obviously and we have a capacity to
destroy and to kill each other and a
capacity to be curious and I think that
that curiosity is our species that it's
best I've wanted to taste things wanted
to learn things wanted to find out
wanting to listen that's the best
quality we have history mostly gets
taught about the destruction bit we
focus on wars we focus on leaders who
kill each other win wars and we
celebrates those who fight and crew and
break things down but that curiosity of
ideas is absolutely its strongest in in
Asia so but again when we there are
spikes when there are financial
resources that allow that to happen so
in particular in the Middle East in the
arabic-speaking world that profound
spike comes around about the Year 700 or
so where the most lucrative parts of the
old Persian party in Empire and of the
old Roman Empire Egypt plug in together
by sound teams put under proper pressure
nearly nearly snuffs it and that world
that is rich curious starts to attract
mathematic mathematicians whether
they're Hindu or the Buddhists but from
India they try to attract scholars from
the Greek world as well to drag people
in together to share ideas and the
geographers in the Arab world in India
eight or nine hundred start to run at
Massoud II says it describes all the
world and he explains why it is that the
Indians are great philosophers why they
are so important in their concepts of
trigonometry and the use of astrology
and when astrology astronomy big upon
and they just and then when he reaches
Europe he says there's just no point me
explaining the content of Europe and
we struggle to understand where these
scholars that produced Pythagoras and
Euclid and Ptolemy
where are they because we venerate the
work of these of these great individuals
and but we can't understand where where
they went and they speculate era
speculated it's because of the tyranny
of Christianity and religious
fundamentalism and we find a good answer
to that in Augustine of Hippo one of the
great church fathers who says it's not
the role of humans to question what God
put on this world
you should be accepting rather than ask
too many questions and of course it's
obviously exactly the opposite way
around today with Isis and its return
towards a sort of seventh century of no
questioning at the expense of your life
and we in the West understand the
curiosities but that passion for
understanding Aristotle for
understanding mathematics is is
all-embracing and that the great
scholars like even sinner writing in
what's now it was Becca ston you know
it's it's it's it's fabulous to read you
know I I had to study Aristotle ISM as
an undergraduate and I'm not necessarily
above average intelligence but I'm above
average educational standards and I
found our sort of impossible to
understand I couldn't understand what
was important and why I couldn't
understand which bits were exciting and
which bits were mundane and but when I
read it in cinah I was one of the great
greatest philosophers in the Arab world
he writes thousand years ago he says I
was told to read the Nicomachean ethics
and I restored I couldn't make head or
tail of it and it troubled me I couldn't
sleep I read it 40 times I couldn't
understand which bits and I mean and and
a flattering to following his footsteps
and he says but what made sense was that
one day I went to the market and I saw a
sort of what they call an idiot's guide
to Aristotle or Aristotle for dummies
that explained it and I sat down and it
suddenly the light bulb came over my
head and it all made sense and fell into
place and that's more or less how I
understood Aristotle to was some sort of
a PIFAN e moment where you realize that
you've been trying to make sense of it
in a differ
and this passion for trying to make to
understand the world around try to find
out the best ideas about mathematics
fits alongside people's curiosity about
which are the best furs to keep you warm
in the winter where did the best arrows
come from where the best saddles made
look and I see you writing again about
where the finest ceramics are made he
sort of gives advice saying never buy
figs from Damascus because they never
taste of anything and they're massively
overpriced you know that that's
important in a world that's curious and
wants to retain knowledge so it can
learn and share from it and that
exchange is is multilateral it's in all
directions but it does follow it does
follow patronage and it follows
self-confidence self-confident open
societies are willing to ask questions
and willing to have their minds changed
about things well I can't run which sort
of Ocean's eleven film it is but the
Byzantine world the Byzantine Empire is
the color is the key to all of this
insofar as it provided the sir the DNA
double helix to understand that that
that the Byzantium world to really make
sense of it you need to understand the
world as 360 degrees from Scandinavia to
the Slavs to the Arab world to the
Persian Gulf to trade ritual kingship
kinship and the Byzantines and their
success for a thousand years of creating
a stable political system that is multi
climatic multi-regional multilingual
multi-ethnic multi-religious that that
stability and that ability for
information to be constantly passing
through Constantinople gathering is is
essentially mice the Silk Roads book in
fine point I could never written this
without being a peasant because this
world is absolutely
the Gateway to understanding all of the
Silk Road so if those don't want to
start to look at the Silk Roads and
global history start with the Byzantium
world because all these questions that's
where they've come from the question how
do people travel how do you gather
information how do you create stable
government how do you create tax and of
course it's one of the great tragedies
in our world that we don't in Europe
anyway validate or value the Byzantine
world the Bizon took the word Byzantine
or Byzantine it's hugely negative in
British language politicians use it
always to mean over administrative
overcomplicated rather than a byword for
all the good things that we should learn
about so the the key to understanding
how a jigsaw is all interlinked all
comes from from the Byzantine Empire
seeing might that's how it brought me
there of seeing how interconnections and
modulations in exchange the challenges
and the opportunities that gave and in
fact the book I wanted to write was
really about Constantinople from 300 to
15 1600 that's what I wanted to do and
look at this big patch and when we were
talking about it with my editor he said
do you think you could bring it up to
the modern day and I said absolutely no
chance and he said please very nicely
and offer to buy me a bottle of wine and
I said well look I will you know I would
I can see why that's important to try to
connect the past more to the modern
world for something like this and I said
but I'm not I've got nothing to say
there's no point me writing it and I was
very lucky that as it happened WikiLeaks
and you know the presidential archive
underneath Saddam Hussein's palace the
tapes were all published because he
recorded everything that 20th century
the sort of the production of materials
that allowed allowed something new to be
said about the 20th and 19th centuries
meant that after two years of working on
it I said I think maybe I can try and
then I spent another two or three years
actually writing is and you know so I
think that the trying to connect and
Byzantium is the link between the past
and the present
you know and those of you who have the
hellenic studies program understand that
too and these complicated questions of
how does ancient athens connect through
beyond and
not easy ones to answer but that bridge
provides the key and like I said it
provides the it's it's like discovering
the double helix so this is how if you
can alter it for Byzantium you can
answer it for the much wider period and
much wider region and so as I could
never have done this without without
that was my background yes well I think
it's a it's a very it's a very tricky
question and it depends how one
hypothesizes these things but I think
it's the starting point is that why is
it that castle building and aristocratic
elites are dominate the history of
medieval Europe and they don't exist in
these they don't exist in the Byzantine
Empire families in Byzantium can compete
for normally one or two generations
unless they're part of the Imperial
elite aneema men it doesn't happen there
is a constant drive towards meritocracy
you know if you're not good enough you
get the chop and there are some not many
exceptions of that rule and it's the
same further east as well you know where
are the Ottoman elites whether in the
Middle where in the Arab world even in
tribal systems there was a constant
recycling of who has power and so I
think it starts begging the question
what is it in Europe that people feel
the need to reinforce their building to
protect their assets why we against that
process why do we why do we work in a
different direction
I suppose one hypothesis would be
because our markers in Europe are are
are so few we're the resources here when
we can grow crops more or less anywhere
there's no gold red and silver not much
tin but those precious commodities
because we don't have them their silks
their ceramics whatever are the desire
to create hierarchies and protect those
hierarchies perhaps that's why we're
more it's more pronounced it's very
speculative it's easy to say it's
actually writing you know
going to more detail needs a bit me
needs me but bit less glib but there is
there is something about the rhythm of
social structures in Europe that it
looks to me very different and requires
some answer my guess is that maybe it's
because we are all too similar and
that's why we have developed different
languages that's why we developed so
many political units so that in 1500
there were 500 political units in Europe
which is you know the size of Kazakhstan
Europe it's not you know and those 500
units constantly fought each other to
the point that those 500 by 1900 became
25 so that process of the strong eating
and devouring the weak of constantly
competing and in that competition
has its benefits too it's not in the
case of England but you know it's
produced sporting excellence it's
produced innovation you know the upside
to constantly competing has that there
are many good things that come from that
too you know when I was a boy aged 13 we
had 250 boys in my year we were all put
in the theater something like this and
had our names read out in reverse order
of how we did in our school exams and
the bottom three were told in front of
the whole year general total failures
and that idea that you are you need to
do better
you need to accumulate more you need to
compete you need to fight is a rhythm
that is very different even and even in
the in the in the eastern Mediterranean
in the East as well that process of
maybe it's because of there isn't of
civic life as well there are natural
limits to how big cities could be built
in climatic zones that are warm until
air conditioning and so on and so forth
so it meant that cities in Europe grew
much bigger and that also galvanized
competition and trade I also haven't
thought about it and be I'm probably not
qualified to really answer that well but
you know the the change of the city and
the change the rise of mega cities in
China is I think one of the most
interesting questions there is right now
for the current urban plan for Beijing
envisages a population of hundred
million people and that starts to raise
questions about water supply resources
food
energy and so on and because our because
we live in the present you know we don't
envisage what the what the what the
challenges that might present to us here
in the West is but China's economic plan
at the moment runs out till 20 49 in
Britain we've got an idea why economic
plan is at the end of this month because
of you know because it breaks it so I
think that the in China that there is
going to be changed because of
urbanization but you know that's not all
Bennis entire success the cities in
western China had a lot of
infrastructure built that's a big
slowdown right now but you know you know
in in Greece as well the Chinese are
thinking very strategically in terms of
the acquisition of the port of Piraeus
and of other investments that that
processes of diversification of
constructing long term plans is part of
what that changing world around us looks
like yes Byzantium is written by Anna
Kamini the Alexia had written in the in
the 1147 fifties that is required
reading for anybody who ever wants to
know anything about Constantinople it's
the worst years of my life translating a
text because it's so hard to both do
justice and to capture the nuance of a
language of a scholar of someone whose
frames of reference I'm aware working in
a world that you know but that is the
best single book about the Byzantine
Empire that you could ever hope and it's
in it the pages turn themselves it's
it's longer than my book by the way but
it's that is what you should read in
terms of English language I mean there
are some terrific terrific books it
depends a little bit on what your what's
your interests are you know I have a
still soft spot for Steven Runciman who
wrote who writes lyrically he may his
interpretations may not quite be bogus
at the moment but there's lots of good
several Cameron writing about the bazan
teens you know there are a lot of
terrific scholars writing about bids on
its own and and percent units all and
the wider orbit starts start with Anna
Kamini then don't go to procopius but
don't don't believe everything you read
in the books
one more and then everyone can have a
glass of what I told the glass of wine
never goes away
one more okay yes we have a drink this
is what this is what political science
is all about but I think the return of
history I'm not scoping I think that
what what I'm trying to flag with that
is that we need to understand the past
and we need to look at the past in a
different way
you know historians are not a luxury in
humanities programs you know we are not
easier Turek looking at small pockets of
the past that have no link into today
that return of history is fundamental
and in departs the world that I look at
like I said that parts of the world I
think matter control of the past is
central and political dialogue so in
advance turkey in putin's russia in
china today in india pakistan
even with even with isis - the
fundamental political point-scoring and
the framing of what's happening the
world is all done with reference to the
past you know in the latest edition of
the in-house isis magazine it's all
about the 7th century and about the
emperor heraclius and the campaigns of
the arab armies against the byzantine
empire i mean they have that if that's
also on your reading list - if you want
to read about Byzantium but also don't
believe everything you read there either
but that the past is alive and battled
the control of the past is absolutely
central so the return of history is not
I'm not trying to predict what political
systems will look like I think we've all
been around the block to know that what
liberal democracy brings in its best
are those tolerances that prevent us
from doing harm to each other it's no
coincidence that even an established
what used to be called liberal
democracies we experienced improper
problems with that as a concept whether
it's through Donald Trump or the rise of
the FDA in Germany or
the kinds of problems we see all over
Europe right now and beyond that the
rise of a far-right that is intolerant
that doesn't want to share these kind of
common bonds that we have with our with
our fellow men and women but so I think
it's just a point that we need to
reflect better on other people's
histories we need to reflect better on
our own past to understand where we fit
into the grand scheme of things rather
than that sort of story of mythologies
where we're convinced that we are the
source of lightness and other people
should be more like us
the Romans felt that at a certain time
too the Byzantines felt that a certain
time too in that moments of change
having the humility to listen I think is
important and that starts with learning